so a couple of weeks ago he said the art
of the deal is one of the greatest books
of all time suck into the Bible right
really it's the second greatest book of
all time
not great expectations or Huckleberry
Finn of the rise and fall of the old
Arabia Roman Empire get Moby Dick now ok
so then so they kind of got himself into
this pickle where he has to defend his
knowledge of the Bible they asked him a
couple of weeks ago with his favorite
passage was he was I don't like to say
too personal they asked him again this
week and he got caught he said his
favorite passage was from Proverbs never
been to envy and they looked it up it
doesn't exist and they nothing even
close to it and Bobby Jindal had a great
line he said the reason we know he's
never read the Bible he's not in the
Bible that as well let's see here's the
thing Bobby Jindal he's not in the King
James Version he's got his own version
as he has a version of everything it's
the the King Trump Bible training
there's a shiny right would you like to
hear some passages from the King drum
fire
in the beginning the earth was without
form and void like jeb Bush's campaign
the earth was very low-energy on a way
out of Sodom and Gomorrah Lot's wife
looked back because it turned into a
pillar of salt but let's face it she
wasn't like a 10 anymore job right out
to God my God why hast thou forsaken me
and the Lord said because you're a loser
and your crops are terrible it is easier
for a camel to pass through the eye of a
needle than for a rich man to get into
heaven I will build a needle so
world-class a herd of camels to get
through it and I will make God pay for
it bless it out of me because they're
really terrific people and they love me
the meek are going to inherit so much
they're going to get tired of inheriting
you